take it easy I'm not injuring you buddy
whoa whoa you nervous I'm so nervous
you're so nervous Tyler Hubbard solo
artist this was a career shift going
from being in a Duo Florida Georgia Line
it was definitely unexpected and
something that BK came to me and wanted
to do and we already got a number one we
do that feels good yeah
[Music]
of course five foot nine isn't just
number one it's a hit on Tick Tock God
makes five foot nine
and there are 17 more tracks on Tyler's
debut solo album Tyler Hubbard out
Friday Peter's songs written with some
Heavy Hitters like Thomas Rhett Bebe
rexa and Keith Urban what is a writing
session like with Keith Urban you just
kind of let Keith new Keith you know
Keith pace which is really fast just a
huge honor he's a good buddy and a great
guy and someone I really look up to
do you and Brian ever talk about
revisiting maybe collaborating again in
the studio or on tour at some point in
time I'm open to it I literally Say
Never Say Never and you never really
know but I will also say it's going to
be a while because I'm having a whole
lot of fun doing what I'm doing now
[Music]
Tyler and I met up at the Brentwood
Skate Center in Tennessee
I bet you didn't know this guy loves to
skate the wheels and his baby gets her
loving music video are the ones he wore
in high school
[Music]
did a kids skate your kids not yet but
we're gonna they actually ice skate
do you feel like you're saying any sort
of musician possibly there with one of
the kids I think so I mean they all
really love music
[Music]
speaking of family I noticed some new
ink on that hand of yours I do have some
new ink this is Daddy this is Mama this
is the three kids this kind of
represents my family and uh just rebirth
and and growth and change and New
Seasons they are cute kids it is
hopefully you and Haley have more just
saying just so I think we're done
[Music]